ses fans l'attendaient depuis six ans le
nouveau disque de bashung sort demain un
album intitulé bleu pétrole le 12e de sa
carrière un disco bashung revient à un
style plus épuré et oui c'est entouré de
collaborateurs de talent eric ornais et
alexandre dupont
dans les étoiles ou sous la douche
tout à leur aise en panneaux
une voix un style toujours aussi
singulier à 60 ans il a toujours des
choses à dire l' envie d'explorer de
nouveaux territoires
après deux albums qui expérimente on ne
plébiscité par la critique voici bashung
revenu aux racines de la pop et du folk
j'ai fait pas mal d'albums qui étaient
des climats parfois surtout le précédent
donc je voulais pas refaire le même je
voulais je voulais refaire quelque chose
qui ressemble à des chansons je me suis
fait aider
aidé par gérard manset ou de jeunes
auteurs comme gaëtan roussel
le chanteur de louise attaque apporte
son mélodies coûts directs ces textes
moins intime davantage tournée vers le
monde voir engagé
ou la rosa les reflets
s'il en résidant de la rue
dans des moments comme ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est de ces que chacun on
propose un petit peu de sa manière de
voir les choses et sa mère de s'exprimer
donc au départ fallait pas à cadrer on a
cadré petit à petit en fonction de ce
que chacun mettez dedans
en quarante ans de carrière de gardien
joséphine en passant par madame rêve et
autres innombrables vertige
bashung avant gardiste a toujours eu un
temps d'avancé
ce douzième album ne déroge pas à la
règle presque déjà cultes comme bashung
l'album
cinq ans je trouvais vieux aux usages
boucle fait du rab a
grandi à construire sur les leurs
et que l'on tient tous les deux sur un
papyrus